been from somebody's Matt Jackson design
director on network so tell us about
that garden tell us what type of game is
this
give us a little bit of information to
the landlord podcast team any
asymmetrical blood work ok let's play in
the future these are five
no they're cool is to complete
objectives to the open exits and estate
both defend the hunter for falling into
hunter isn't all things
that's basically in a nutshell gosh I
mention it's a procedurally generated
environment different every time anyway
in fact is very different spot the crazy
which basket and against this entourage
you okay hundred years
so we're showing off two different
weapon states and he's access to folks
power which we're calling it simply
game-changing see we trust you Tamia
maturity and we have supercharged
basically like
automatically fast yogurt jump really
far
he also has two cubs
to fill up cylinders load ounces of
water
to customize their experience kush and
create their own unique
now first platforms that are this is
coming out for what are we currently
scheduled for a platform eyes for this
game so PC version right now okay and
we're focusing on
to get really good before we ever talk
about any other sounds good
so every we like to get get our hands on
it get take a look at it if we can okay
so what I can do
maybe get you guys in the next round
sounds good okay all do is would you
guys want my hunter or runner or maybe
one of these that's how we do it I am
well but we go at each other sometimes
[Laughter]
about and play with your friends you
guys feel like waiting together yeah
good all right they're really a team
focused a bit something that we really
it's in the bedrock of our design you
know even just down to the fact that one
of our core mechanics is line marking so
like this head like
my day long
the other one
like I couldn't do nothing
okay we gotta go in arguments like I
said I mentioned Courtney you can have
the ability to swallow though the stunt
them to roofie
they're really powerful when you even if
you cannot do damage to doctor can't
damage him the ability to know where he
is on the map for example it's fair your
Wow absolutely anyway absolutely
done exactly right now we're showing off
one objective so that calling a capture
and when the runners are inside the
capture zone okay all I have to do is
stand in that query altimeter and
whether in that soul they are
automatically revealed to the hunter of
all those clashes as much as possible
right even though it is a stealth action
game team we want to create moments
where it forces the runners out of their
usual patterns and enforcement's engage
with the hunter gotcha
this house is really cool a lot of
potential game looks great
the one person it might seem like these
old people very cool
definitely definitely hype about this
game a lot of potential I just make sure
my colleagues get the next round yes
Oh